what are you doing you're not answering
the question I'm asking
I felt so hopeless and so lost and just
unsure of how it's gonna make anything
in my life the things you think are ride
are the things that will blow up hard
work is just always gonna win nice guys
are here five minutes start breaking her
all right sitting here with the legend
every time bill you thank you for
inviting me into your home dude thanks
they're coming man I love it I love it I
can't believe that we're meeting in
person for the first time today it's
been did I have you on it was way back
yeah I remember when I first saw your
stuff because all my stuff gets
requested it's all the people in my
audience in hey can you do this verse
this person right the first time
somebody said Tom bill you like okay
I've never heard of him I'll check it
out you had just finished inside quest
and just started doing impact Theory and
we did a top-10 on you like oh man I
really love this guy Wow and the first
video actually tanked like the first
time bill you video hank hard and I
remember thinking man I really hope this
guy doesn't stop because there's there's
not a lot of great content out there
helping entrepreneurs and I really loved
your message thank you and it's so easy
to get discouraged when you don't see
the initial numbers especially we've had
massive success in a different field and
I was like taking so long that going and
so I'm super pumped that you kept going
obviously built this huge brand now if
we do another time bill your video it
blows up so that's awesome
appreciate it okay so one I want to use
this time wisely I want to talk health
you don't get the business nice okay
health I'm curious if you have solved
the seasonal allergy issue yet not for
me no so I don't I don't experience what
I'll call super seasonal I just have
allergies all the time and so I'm one of
those people if I take my medication I'm
fine but then I think well I'm fine I
should be able to stop taking my
medication and so I'll try it every now
and then and and it just comes rushing
right back it's pretty crazy this
disappoints me so much yeah because I
you you talked about it once on some old
video about how you took a seasonality
pill every day yeah and it stuck because
I do too I'm allergic to grass and dust
and trees you
yeah fantastic yeah I'm like if
anybody's gonna figure it out it's time
here's the problem this is so manageable
so like I really go after things like
inflammation that was untenable in my
life and so that's something that I
definitely put energy into and when I
first did ketogenic s-- which by the way
when I first did it I despised it so
people that are like Iquitos terrible
like I never went I get it I get how
people end up there it you really have
to figure out how to do it well and it
was miserable but my inflammation went
away like like I was taking a drug and
all I had done was changed my food that
was crazy but that was like I had burn
marks on my wrists that I thought were
permanent at the time because I was
icing every day and I would I some
multiple times a day for like 20-30
minutes at a shot just to like be able
to get through my day was really crazy
and then yeah keto completely changed
that this stuff that my wife's come
through with microbiome untenable so
it's like problems will rear their head
and become something that has to be
dealt with my allergies hasn't quite on
that category you're like my spirit
animal Wow right I like that Tom's gonna
figure it out when I found out that you
had this same thing as me like Tom's
gonna figure it out he's gonna do all
the work I've let us both down you need
to bring it on the allergy expert it's
actually interesting that would be a fun
episode to do yeah I would watch that I
will help you pull out that video all
right
I'm stuck to my stick to my pills and
I'm on a pill almost every day all year
long yeah I'm pill and no spray the no
spray though I only have to do probably
four months out of the year okay and
which is weird cuz it's winter so I
don't know what that's about but as I
get into the later months where most
people are having a hard time then I can
stop doing the spray I'm looking at
doing that therapy where they like
injected with a needle every week for
two years or something I know somebody
that did something like that I don't
know if there was an end date for him
but he got injections I don't know if it
was weekly but he said it was a game
changer for him yeah I was hoping I
would come here and get a magical answer
before doing that but yeah I can give
you some my dog has really bad allergies
and so that was so bad for him that we
really had to figure it out so he gets
this like squirt thing in his mouth
every day and it's like a low-level
of like some crate like 22 different
compounds that he's allergic to and so
just by getting a little bit of exposure
every day yeah it's helped okay so I
don't know maybe there's only got spray
Wow okay
disappointing cool I love it okay
my favorite question and you asked on
health theory is your last one
yeah and sometimes it gets so pissed off
because it's the answer is totally
irrelevant to the rest of the talk you
have the keto guy on who's then talk at
the end says relationships there's a
number one thing that right right what's
your last question what's the most
simple what's the impact you want to
have on the world well do the hell on
Hell theory it's if you could change one
thing that would have the biggest impact
on people on their health movie I like
the impact Theory one because it's it's
a nice ending but that one you almost
always get some wild answer or at least
half the time has nothing to do with the
show and then there's not enough time
that you're such a great thread puller
like of interview because you spend so
much time researching people it it it is
obvious and people always come on it's
like how did you know that about me both
because Tom's doing the work that dive
into your entire life story he knows it
and then and then you follow your
curiosity and you're such a good thread
color but then I want to know why the
kedo guy says relationships is the most
important thing to fix your health and
it's only you know like a minute and a
half answer yeah have you thought about
switching that I haven't partly because
it is interesting sort of in isolation
because if I brought it in too early
than I think a lot of the interviews
would take on the more philosophical
tone because people are trying to either
give you something that's in their
wheelhouse so the sleep guy will tell
you that it's sleep the hydration
person's didn't tell you that it's water
but you do every now and then get these
really random answers that I actually
wouldn't want to get earlier because
then to pull that thread to follow up on
it to not make it completely a non
sequitur which works at the end but
wouldn't work earlier in the episode
there's a lot of pressure on people with
that question and so I find that it can
go in these very interesting directions
which is fun is a point on the end of it
but wouldn't take the the interview
where I want to go it's so I often don't
know what they're gonna say and if you
want to know a little bit about my
interview style I once heard that a DA
is never gonna ask you a question to
which he does not already know the
answer and I thought that's an
interesting tactic so in my interviews
I'll say 80% of the questions I'm asking
because I know where you're gonna go and
and I think that it's gonna add a lot of
value to people so I'm steering them
towards that I'm pulling threads because
one I am following my curiosity but too
often times I know they've got something
deep wisdom down that thread and I just
need to get them there and if I were
asking that question which I usually
don't know the answers I don't know if
they're gonna be philosophical I don't
know if they're gonna be obvious it's
better as a punctuation hmm I think
that's how you actually create unique
content a lot of the people who will
come on they've been on a lot of other
shows and better set stories ready to go
and I think you doing your intro and and
then asking questions don't know the
answer to helps but to have unique
amazing content it's asking questions
that they haven't been asked anybody
else's show maybe but I think that the
reality is on a long enough timeline
that'll actually be a losing strategy
for me maybe maybe other people could
pull it off and maybe that's some of the
magic of Joe Rogan is that he's going
places that it is I think it was will
who was just off-camera minute ago said
that Joe Rogan has an element of chaos
his interview certainly when you take
them as a gestalt so it's like even you
as the listener no idea where this one's
gonna go is it going to be combative is
it gonna be you know where they're going
down really random rabbit holes they can
be talking about hunting like you never
know what you're gonna get and that one
is not the current skill set that I have
so I could develop a skill set maybe
that would let me do an interview style
like that but for me it's about taught
trying to pre masticate their entire
world so I know how they think I know
how they're gonna answer most questions
and and from that I can ask myself
simple questions what will be most
valuable to my audience so the one thing
that I try to hold myself accountable to
is not just am I
to be entertained not just am I going to
learn something but is the audience
going to be able to get something they
can actually take away so I'm so sincere
at the very beginning of my interview
when I say that the whole idea behind
this company is to introduce you to the
people and ideas that will help you
actually execute on your dreams so I the
show that I'm trying to do now is one
where you can with every show get a
brick and with that brick you can build
something whether that's a more powerful
mindset whether that's a better business
whether that's to be a better parents or
have a better relationship depending on
the show it's that's where I'm going
and so to leave it to chance to be like
I don't know where you're gonna go and
I've been interviewed like this and
people will take me to places I don't
have profound wisdom so now it's like
yes you may have gotten something
interesting because maybe you tap into
something that nobody else has tapped
into but it's also possible you take me
somewhere where I'm really ineffective
which i think is is it's a higher-risk
interview certainly so my goal with the
the intro is to I want to rob you of
your normal story I'm trying to get you
out of what I call your loop because it
drives me nuts when no matter what I ask
people and I won't say who but I've had
people on the show yeah where I'm like
what are you doing you're not answering
the question I'm asking so and I already
gave the audience your loop so all the
things you're really proud of all that
I've already said it it's in the intro
people get it and so that to me was yes
I want to honor them but I also want to
take away the typical way that they talk
about their story so I want to go a
level deeper but I want to go a level
deeper in areas that I know you have
deep wisdom my favorite moments from
your interviews are when people give you
an answer and then you're like wow that
was not what I expected
yeah that's fun like when they have
something that's real and it's like wow
that's really usable in my life yeah
those are my favorite moments as well I
think that's the genius of time Billy
well thank you I think that's the whole
thing yeah that's it's interesting I
don't think of that as the whole thing I
think of that as because I am when you
really know a topic like you actually
know it people can take you into weird
places and you'll do well because you
understand the fundamentals right so I'm
I always love when somebody says
something that I'm surprised by
and those moments happen because I've
hopefully taken them somewhere that I
know that they're good that they have
interesting thing to say and oftentimes
it's people will mention like I just
watched so much footage on them that
they'll do a throwaway comment in
another interview that nobody follows up
in and based on what I know about them I
have a high probability that they have
something really interesting to say
there so I'll follow up with that but it
really is just like do I know this
person well enough to go into crazy
places with them and have the confidence
to be like I'm gonna be able to piece
this back together for people because I
know their worldview and I I secretly
want my whatever success I have from the
method that I use to be proof that hard
work is just always gonna win the one
thing I do sometimes think is is
unearned is my curiosity and that
bothers me I don't like anything in my
personality to be unearned but I didn't
do anything to cultivate my curiosity
I've always had curiosity and so in the
interview I get the visceral like whoa
what was that and then I actually want
to know and so I'm gonna chase them down
and then not being afraid to look stupid
so I'll just keep asking until I
actually understand from someone who
consumes a ton of content I probably
watch more of everybody's videos anybody
for what I do I would love for you to
dedicate I have to show to it and if you
go nowhere you still got the first half
of the show interesting because there's
some of the guests you have on I've seen
in other spots and so I would love
impact theory to be the show that man if
Tom has them on it's gonna be it's gonna
be the best interview that person's ever
done it's really interesting and so to
get that you're saying to ask more what
all call high-risk questions where I
have no idea where this is gonna go well
ain't following your curiosity I think
that's the genius I do follow my
curiosity so that I will say sort of is
it true is it regardless it comes close
to being regardless if something really
sparks my curiosity now here's something
maybe you can help me with and I really
do struggle with this I will have
watched so much footage on that person
before they come in that a lot of times
like if they're even getting close to
their loop it's like I know this already
so I'm not having an emotional reaction
which
then if I'm not having the emotional
reaction I can't necessarily take them
somewhere surprising and so there are
times when like I can't get this person
out of their loop and that gets really
frustrating and in those moments I am
trying to like sort of push and poke I'm
probably just not good enough yet well
great it's an aspiration to get better
at yeah for sure
I think those are the moments I mean you
you get a guy like Goggins on and you
you guys both kind of blew up together
right yeah that dude he blew you up and
and you blew him up and and it was a
magical moment for both of you but
Goggins brings fire everywhere he goes
and it is right and so what when the
interaction comes with Tom what's Tom
I'm gonna bring you out that's different
because people are in their loop longer
stories and I mean I'm just maybe
hearing it so often when we're looking
at these people that were profiling I
would love to say man this is why I
subscribe to impact theory is you're
gonna get something different it's
really interesting you're putting your
finger on something so behind the scenes
we're trying to develop a new show and
it's to introduce the chaos factor I
wouldn't have said it quite like you're
saying it but I want to get to the point
where it can be sort of a collision of
ideas because that's where I've always
thought is the most interesting
interview so if you watch my early
inside quest interviews I talked a lot
more than I do now and that I stopped
doing that because I could see a way to
get bigger guests on the show if I
created a way for them to really shine
and to just focus entirely on getting
their wisdom and packaging it up and
bringing it to my audience and that's
worked really really well and so I
wouldn't ever want to stop doing that
but I do want a show that's that has
that element of chaos like did you see
the episode that we did with Dame - I'm
a little behind this I'm on my tour dude
fair enough but yeah yeah we got so much
pumped for I'm pumped for it it it's the
weirdest interview I've ever done okay
so it did well yeah did very well as
well on my channel - it's like he's a
very interesting and a high level of
chaos yeah yeah a high level of chaos
you never know what you
get this is California I don't want to
speak out of school but when we weren't
filming he was definitely partaking of
certain legal substances in the state of
California and it was just on my mind
like what it did for him so I've smoked
weed before and it does not affect me in
a positive way I hate it man the only
thing it does it makes sex better it's
amazing for that like amazing but every
single thing else sucks so I just I
can't watch movies I have a hard time
like paying attention to the plot it
doesn't make me feel more creative it's
not like I could write better so for me
like there is exactly one use for it but
the problem is it lasts the effects left
last five hours so I'm always intrigued
when people are like they purport to be
at their best when they're doing it so I
was like I have to ask so we're doing
the whole normal interview we wrap last
question what's the impact you want to
have in the world he answers it but he
ends up saying something really weird I
don't remember what triggered it but he
said something really weird so I
couldn't just let his last answer go so
I started like pulling up the thread I'm
following my curiosity I'm like I need
to know more about that and so he really
starts giving it to me he lets his guard
down he just talking it's awesome and
I'm like well now that we're having the
real interview why do you smoke weed
like I got an out like what is it and so
then we go down this crazy rebel it was
so much fun we started talking about
quantum physics and like crazy and I had
so much fun but I was like I have no
idea of people watching this or like
what is this and people were meaning the
part about the quantum physics but it
was rad and so I want to find a format
that can handle a bit more
experimentation that would be a lot of
fun but it would also require a
different kind of guest because a lot of
if a guess is like ultra packaged I'm
never gonna be able to gather I think
that's where your genius can
breakthrough legit I look at TD jakes
you know T V J yeah TD jakes when he's
done some of his interviews he's fire
like TD jakes when he's on fire is
untouchable
he's he's a special kind of human but
he's also had some really born
interviews
based off of who's asking the questions
I think you can take people there
interesting man
I appreciate that that's really you
think the fun the thing that you love
the most going down that rabbit hole is
gonna create such amazing stuff and
people come and watch because you're
putting them on most of the people
you've had on they haven't been massive
names yet why are people watching is
because tom is recommending them because
you saw something in this person people
have trust in you that if Tom's gonna
put them on they have to have something
that's it's another brick right right
that I'm gonna learn from and so the
more curious you are the more the
audience is gonna care too as opposed to
you've like I've heard this loop before
the arms gonna feel like that too
yeah like no I don't fight before like I
want it right okay switching the
business I got a special surprise here
oh my man there it is okay listen I'm on
a 90-day tour right now yes so so we're
driving across Wow
North America that's incredible us doing
because we have all of this gear and
everything to make it happen yeah so so
bringing this shirt down just for this
episode taken isn't it it's one of my
few t-shirts that I'm bringing along
just for this but thank you one of the
things that you always do when you're
interviewing people is you always try to
wear something that is inspired by them
Yeah right so there you go this is a
missus for you don't know this is the
arms comic that he did with Steve Aoki
yep
neon future that's the one and you sent
me a whole bunch of them I haven't
opened them because it's like I want to
read them but I don't open them because
they're interesting yes I believe it is
I want I want people to like dig in and
read the story but I totally get it as a
psycho collector myself trust me I'll
give you one and like scuff it a bit so
you're like all right well this is
garbage yeah but this is so moving on
the business yeah why don't we see more
Tom on Tom's channel you know it's an
interesting question so that goes back
to this other show where I want to be I
want to be talking more quite frankly so
that I can explore my own ideas I very
much am a process thinker so for me to
you even get through my own ideas I need
to be able to talk about them and so it
would be very useful in my own life to
have those moments where I could talk
about it and it really comes down to
time n my time is I have officially hit
the point where I'm willing to work more
but there aren't more hours and that's a
very for a type-a like myself it's a
very frustrating place to be to know
that you could do more you could give
more but you're now officially at the
point where like for instance if I don't
give my relationship enough hours it
begins to decline it's my highest
priority so I have to make sure that I'm
allocating the time and energy to that
so what if you do one interview a week
well that's one more interview a week
that's the problem so right now and look
it is possible and I don't want to find
that a hundred percent but I just start
thinking about okay something has to
give so what's important enough to give
for this and we were just having this
debate yesterday and we were talking
about whether we should be doing a
relationship theory and so that's a show
that constantly finds itself on the
chopping block because it's so different
than other things we do but the show
itself is good for my marriage so that's
why it keeps getting a fighting chance
I love it it's my favorite to do first
of all and I really feel like some of
the techniques at least and I have
figured out would be really useful for
people it's a lot of fun for me to talk
about it's the most sort of raw business
is very procedural I do enjoy talking
about that but there's something about
relationships man that that is really
rad but I think my fantasy show would be
something where it's a bit more timely
it's a bit more wildcard it's the guest
comes in but they would have to know
what to expect and this is also part of
what throws the show off is just making
sure that we've got enough T's in the
can that people really understand what
the show is and we shot a pilot episode
of this and it was it was a dog it was
terrible and so we're like okay that
clearly wasn't the format but something
where I can ask questions that are gonna
be off topic for that guest so that it's
more time
asking questions of people which is the
other problem so how do I inject myself
so by the way OHS but but you don't just
want to be Larry King
I think you are Larry King to be honest
like I think you are the next generation
of Larry King come on Charlie Rose sure
forget all that
I'm talking on camera great boy that
that soundbite just turned it's parable
for any interview style right yeah I
always thought he was great at poker but
if you take Oprah and Charlie and Larry
yeah maybe a handful of other people
like that's the old generation I said
you have but it's not even it's not even
your best skill set so any of you is
actually a mentor me so what does the
what does this show look like
functionally like in terms of the layout
is it an interview style show is it sort
of a hybrid with like the way that I do
my AMA is where I am literally just
talking so I think the problem of the
AMA is the same problem Gary had with
his askgaryvee show it's just - all over
the place you don't know what you can
expect it's like the questions are all
it's marketing and then it's mindset and
then it's raising capital and then it's
really all over the place where at least
if you're doing it with that where the
guess is some kind of structure like I
like this person well you're diving
deeper into their world the other series
you had I never enjoyed like the quotes
one the yelling one impact okay but but
that's fine like thank you it's fine I
don't I loved you for how inquisitive
you are and and your strategies and your
ideas not the I don't want you to get
motivated well that's interesting so in
that sounds like a conundrum to me so if
what you like about me is my
inquisitiveness how do I talk without
getting in the way of my inquisitiveness
I think you marry them so I think the
things that you think about that make
you so inquisitive and you've learned
all this stuff is why I asked about
allergies like you're my spirit animal
for this stuff it's like tom has done
all the work to figure it out and he's
gonna share it and I get to learn and
pick your brain from all the work that
you've done and it saves me the time to
have to do it just like what I do with
my top tens like I watch all of this
stuff and this saves my audience a time
to have to go watch four hours of you
long wants to get a 20 minute video I
think I think that's your strength
somebody asked me Gary Vee you're Tom
Beal you who do you like better
it's like I'll pick Gary for YouTube and
Tom for Instagram interesting I love
your Instagram Thank You Man the part
that I love and and I love your YouTube
too but it's not there's no Tom on your
YouTube anymore it's only your guests
which is great and you asked my favorite
questions of all time but it's not even
your greatest skill set what I love
about you like how Tom Bilyeu has
impacted everyone Carmichael's life the
most is your willingness to be humble
and share your past story and what
you're currently going through to not be
just pushing the home and the cars and
the all of that stuff that most people
are pushing on Instagram so when you go
and you show your picture and look at my
big ears right or this is the car that
you know I used to drive around in the
past and showing that's what you came
from but also the newer stuff of when
you're setting up your comic convention
and like you're there with the sign and
you're standing on the stool or whatever
you're standing on and seem like I'm
still here doing the work even though
I've made all this money I'm still off
I love the humbleness it's something
that that inspires me as a human man
thank you but that's nowhere on your
YouTube channel
the only Tom is the great questions and
then the the rants the yelling stuff
which is fine I'm not it's just not my
style it's okay dude I worship at the
feet of direct communication so it's
amazing I don't know how you bring that
in but I think your humility and your
willingness to still do all the dirty
work and willingness to still work
insanely hard yourself is one of the
greatest lessons that you can give to
this generation of entrepreneurs and so
it doesn't exist anywhere on your
YouTube channel but it's pretty
prevalent on your Instagram mm-hmm
that's such a powerful Inside Man I'm
really really grateful for that
and here's just speaking
extemporaneously here's what I have
tried to do on my Instagram page so yes
definitely like the old stories this is
where I came from because that like when
I really think about what's the impact I
want to have on the world it's to show
people that it does not matter
where you are today it only matters who
you want to become and the price you're
going to pay to get there and I it makes
me sad for other people that they think
that I have some natural talent and that
they then let themselves off the hook
because of that because let me tell you
when I was laying in bed four hours a
day every day in the morning I didn't
feel talented I'll just tell you that
like I felt like a loser
social media didn't exist there was no
way for me to reach out to people and
connect with these thought leaders you
could get Tony Robbins tapes and books
and stuff and that's what I did but it's
like man that's pretty far cry from
where things are today and so I I felt
so hopeless and so lost and just unsure
of how it's gonna make anything in my
life and so for people to be like oh
well easy for you to say you have XYZ
talents like really truly I do not I had
zero instincts as an entrepreneur coming
into it I was a buffoon fell on my face
embarrass myself I'm just stupid beyond
all imagining but the that's part of it
for Instagram the other part is I don't
want to be in the world of platitudes I
want to be in the world of like okay I
have to give you something pretty
complex fast because I get the nature of
Instagram but I try to give as much real
no-bull like a lot of times the team
will ask me for something and be like
write something on this and I'm like but
that's not the truth like the truth is
that he had this weird messy thing over
here but I'm so grateful for them
pushing me to try to like make this
simple thing and it's like why isn't
that platitude true okay it's because of
this thing over here and so it's
interesting sadly I couldn't put it
together as concrete as that whole
experiment thing that I'm trying to do
over here on Instagram is missing from
YouTube because I'm always working via a
proxy to get other people to say it
because I feel like it is there in some
ways coming out in the interviews so
that's a very helpful mental construct
thank you it's not communities no I'm
gonna appreciate that it's the impact
that you want to have wherever you are
it's not just Instagram is this one
strategy and YouTube is a totally
different vibe mmm
if that's the impact you want to have
and showing that side then then it's now
just how do we make that into a
long-form video right telling the story
I don't know that I had the answer of
how do you turn it into a ten minute
video because that's what YouTube wants
for the algorithm but if it's you
retracing your steps are you showing a
picture of you and you write like pages
on Instagram right like you pour your
heart there's a lot of time you spend on
the captions you could tell it's not
just some throwaway hey guys this was me
okay hustle right go right so how do you
turn that then into a video with with
sound effects and show pictures of you
and yeah maybe it's that easy
just that side I'd love to see I think
you coaching somebody would be amazing
well now if my wife is eavesdropping in
on this she has a whole show idea her in
the show runner for impact Theory have
this idea of me so we did a show a long
time ago called driver dream roulette
and at the time I was commuting like 40
minutes each way and I would always do
it new burrs and I just found that if
you start asking them questions most of
them have some sort of side hustle and
so we would start talking and I'd ask
questions and then if I could be useful
I would you know say hey here's what
I've learned and sometimes got really
interesting so I started recording it on
my iphone and ultimately it was a
terrible use of time because for every
five times I tried to do it only one was
good and so then once it was like a show
and I was filming it there were times
where I would just have to drive around
in an uber trying to get a good one
that's right like this is terrible
but they want to partner with you know
lyft or uber or somebody like that and
so that we're getting people that have
been sort of vetted and then I would
essentially coach them I don't think you
need the gimmick I think you're that
good so how do you find like his now it
comes down to casting you have to get
real people that are really gonna be
interesting and get them through the
system one you're already doing your
event and you're doing your endless AMAs
or Q&A is until whatever in the morning
who was the most interesting person
right there
with somebody and you say these three
people I want to do 20 minutes each on
the next day everybody's gonna say yes
because they love you they're your fans
and then you film three episodes of 20
minutes each and one of them makes it it
it's a pretty reasonable solution right
or or you have people come here right
like apply send in your video of what
you want to learn from Tom and then
you're already doing your other stuff
here anyway you just have to show up for
an hour you go through three 20 minutes
at a time and you coach them and you
help them and one of the three will will
be good but I don't mind the car thing
it's great but I don't think you need
the gimmick right I think you're good
enough I think you're I think I would
love to watch that just you sitting here
right you know change the color or
something we did it from a business
perspective cuz I always thought that
like when we started this I did not
think I was gonna be the mindset guy I
thought I was gonna be the business guy
and so we had a show called startup
theory and I was advising people on
their businesses but it was to business
focused and so it's like it got so
specific to like if you were there was
one guy was doing something like sports
recruiting or something like that and so
it got so intense about sports
recruiting that even though it was great
advice if I do say so myself it was like
if you weren't building that business it
wasn't mindset it was like real business
tactics so yeah doing that show but on a
mindset focus more without letting it
become just about business they all what
whatever their business problem is is
actually a mindset problem it's not
always true and I do like if we're gonna
do a business show it's like I want it
to be real I don't want it to be bull I
want to like course and so there you
have to get and sometimes it's gonna be
like hey that's a limiting belief
whatever we have to get rid of that what
not when is it not that it's it's just
legit a business issue and not it
because with the right mindset you
figure anything out sort of so yes
that's true but the show becomes about
the and now figure it out like if you've
already got the mindset component
otherwise that show would largely be the
same over and over and over and over and
over because it would be like alright
you have a mindset problem let's fix
your mindset if you're gonna do a
business show I think you want to
actually get into the business and maybe
I'm completely delusional I can't see
past that right now
if the setup is that this is about
helping somebody with their mindset and
either they're struggling at work or
they're struggling in their home life
like if we were to reduce the questions
that I get an ama which is my favorite
show to do by the way that would be
incredible I got lost in thought because
the the thing that I think would be our
greatest piece of content is the endless
QAS where it's live and I'm on stage
there's nowhere to hide I've got a mic
and a line of people that want problem
solved
that's rad because that like that's hard
like can you really solve this person's
problem in real time with an audience
there's no room for error and I think
that that's me at my best I I think so
too
I think pulling the things that you
think are rad is how you're gonna win
whether it's the deme - weed question
that you're like oh and that was a rad
15 minutes extra or the endless Q&A
these are things that nobody does unless
qat your weird duck people don't stick
around till forever to answer
everybody's question does like he go all
in on it
I think that's it that's still the
humility side that I love that here's
this guy who may have been paid money to
come here but then he's gonna spend not
just fly in and out but he's gonna spend
as long as it takes to make sure
everybody got a great experience with
their question answered it's showing
like it's your that is your humility
showing through and used willingness to
work at it I love it I think the real
problem with most business questions is
you can get a text question on an AMA
and I love your a minute I love your
emails more than I love your interviews
cuz it's Tom know they may not have
performed as well cuz they're all over
the place right but I love even though
you try to like okay today we're talking
about this but still you get questions
for all over the place the problem with
it is one you don't get to see the
reaction any of the person yeah and how
much you changed their life right and
and you getting the feedback off of I
just helped that person when you when
you when you catch it you're gonna push
harder on it sure and it's gonna become
amazing versus just a text question on
screen and you're plowing through the
next one and - the major problem is not
the first question is - four questions
deep the question to come in with
another the problem they actually have
right and you'd be really because you
pull on the three you'd be great at be
able to pull that out so that's why I
think having you with somebody for 20
minutes you'll rock their world and it'd
be a huge insight for people to watch
now to start figure out the format may
be a little difficult the probably
wouldn't even do as well as your regular
videos because you're training people to
watch Tom the interviewer right not Tom
the thought leader no which pisses me
off because I love Tom Athaliah
right so when we're looking for content
it's actually harder now because you're
not doing the AMAs to go to other
people's channels to find I'm going on
my podcast now yeah yeah well I don't do
podcasts I want to do it on Bill you
mashup we've got a good at other
people's channels yes yeah yeah it's
great point it's a great point but doing
more of the things that you think are
rad is the answer instead of just
thinking about the audience the things
that I care about all these questions
I'm asking you I care deeply about and
be people who like me who have exposure
to your world too they're gonna find it
interesting because I'm pulling the
thread that I want to pull on them right
right where somebody else has a
different audience they'll care about
different things the things you think
are right are the things that will blow
up so I love the car thing but I don't
you don't think you need the gimmick
because you're that good thank you
Tom man thank you for all the time
really appreciate the the energy the
slime all the work that you do thank you
for your constant help and not only
encouragement but showing us ways that
we could be doing things better I'm sure
you have a sense of how rare that is but
like even before we met face to face you
were like trying to help us you even did
a video one time on us just like here's
everything that's wrong with Tom
Billie's channel okay I was like this is
amazing
like I was freaking out I grabbed
everybody on the team I'm like you have
to watch this video this is so crazy
and the funny thing is I remember I
commented in your thread like dude I
cannot thank you enough for this and
then somebody else was like oh wow so
crazy look how like humble ease being
and I thought a man who is experienced
in this took the time to do an audit of
my channel anybody that doesn't fall
over themselves to be grateful for that
is missing such a huge opportunity so
that's just you you've always been like
that whether it's
facing a camera or a DM or even
literally when you came here almost the
first sentence out of your mouth was I
have some strategies you guys should try
it's like dude that's huge man
I really really can't thank you enough
we need to figure out our communication
because I don't use a cell phone mm and
you don't use email yeah that that's
tricky well the here's the really good
news now I don't use a cell phone either
okay so I have turned off every single
notification in my life so for everybody
watching they want to dive more into
your world what's the next best spot at
tom bill you across socials the places
I'm most active our Instagram and
YouTube YouTube like if you're trying to
do something to show me how much I've
impacted you follow me on YouTube that
would be amazing growing that is the
future of this company if you want to to
actually be interactive with me then
it's gonna be Instagram I love it
Tom bill you thank you if you want more
time bill you check that the top 50
rules video made on him as well the link
is right there next to me I'll see you
there